je le sais ça y est on connaît enfin la
date de diffusion du prochain spectacle
des [ __ ]
ce sera le vendredi 6 mars prochain sur
tf1 bien sûr plein de nouveautés cette
année pour rendre hommage à notre dame
de paris qui a brûlé en avril dernier le
show commencera par il venu le programme
a même été baptisé cette saison le paris
des [ __ ] dans cette nouvelle édition
il devrait y avoir beaucoup moins de
sketches mais on pourra quand même rires
des grandes affaires qui ont marqué
l'année avec par exemple des sketches
sur carlos ghosn ou sur les grèves
côté retour on note celui de la
chanteuse véronique sanson après plus de
20 ans d'absence est celui surprise de
muriel robin une bonne nouvelle
puisqu'on pensait ne plus la revoir avec
la troupe après sa déclaration en 2018
c'est fini je ne mets pas fait une année
parce que j'étais en burn out et j'avais
le temps de me retaper comme d'habitude
les [ __ ] accueil plein de petits
nouveaux cette année les heureux élus
sont les chanteurs vita et slimane et
l'humoriste inné srec et enfin bonne
nouvelle pour finir michael jones l'un
des trois réalisateurs du spectacle
cette année a même laissé sous-entendre
car autour de jean jacques goldman
la figure emblématique des [ __ ]
serait possible un jour fait pas dit que
il ne reviendra pas qu'on entende bien
créé voilà comment une commune comme
nous tous l'an dernier tf1 avait réalisé
l'un des scores les plus bas de
l'histoire des [ __ ] avec 8,9
millions de téléspectateurs alors
vont-ils faire mieux cette saison la
réponse le 6 mars
[Musique]
ça reste lyon 9 ça reste quand même
extrêmement corrects on les met sur la
solution là et en divertissement
oui je peux vous en parler puisque je
suis allé au tournage à bowie avec
brigitte adam bakr aussi légitime bas
brésil pour les français c'est brigitte
douay excuses exact il est salué les
bénévoles 80 de 3000 bénévoles qui
travaillent pour les restos du coeur
alors évidemment l'émission est
absolument magnifique crois que c'est
une des plus belles franchement c'est
c'est la 35e campagne c'est une des plus
belles celle là
l'émission c'était ça rend hommage à la
fois notre dame de paris bien sûr et à
dalida et c'est une déambulation dans
les rues de paris
effectivement on retrouve véronique
sanson où il ya un panneau de fin et
qu'un tableau extraordinaire de faim
avec elle et tous les chanteurs autour
là d'une émotion
grandissime il ya des petits nouveaux
effectivement une estrade cayla genia
semanya vita
si magna était déjà en fait il ya
plusieurs nouveaux chanteurs qui
viennent
c'est formidable c'est ça va être une
très très belle et 12 ans par principe
les restos on va dire pour moi
personnellement on aime plus que ça une
vocation à windham hon au pseudonyme a
cédé 1 dvd ça équivaut à 17h important
c'est très important peut pas donc dédié
s'ils sont trop ils sont trop nombreux
alors les genres et des équipes cette
année ils sont 42 artistes et beau
toujours les mains avec christophe
willem et jean louis aubert liane foly
et cetera nolwenn cloclo de cap et aussi
qui sera là c'est un magnifique explique
maguy vous avez un scoop
plutôt un démenti en fait tout le monde
dit que dazhou aurait refusé et aurait
planté au dernier moment
les restos du coeur ce qui est très
grave pourquoi parce que déjà je le
connais personnellement je connais son
équipe
il n'y a pas plus humain que ces gens là
que cette personne que dazhou son équipe
d'ailleurs gère aussi vite à et slimane
qui sont sur le plateau des [ __ ]
c'est pas vrai il aurait aimé faire il
aurait rêvé le faire il est toujours là
pour les bonnes causes lui et gims et
des gens qui donnent beaucoup et qui
participent beaucoup aux associations
caritatives
maintenant effectivement il ya un
phénomène aujourd'hui sur le web c'est
que tous les rappeurs qui marche qui
cartonne sont souvent des victimes
arrête s'il te plaît il me refais le
truc dans un quart d'heure avec zizou
la vie est angoissant champ des fours
[Rires]
est un film tu fais pas ça injuste et
sur les réseaux parce que tu es sont
systématiquement attaqués de fausses
rumeurs de fausses histoires et cetera
donc je démenti et je vous le demande je
vais manger des bonbons et vas-y à l'est
[Applaudissements]
où avaient été invités il serait allé au
reste du groupe est invité
non ça il n'a pas été invité non pour
l'instant c'est pas encore ça a été mais
si elle s était tourné en même temps ça
s'est un peu tardé 14 juillet juste un
mot c'est vrai qu'à chaque année sur des
petites rumeurs donc c'est moins sympa
que il ya des petites tensions dans les
kiosques et qui donna le nom mais qui
ont les mêmes intérêts
la fonction d'accords femme brune fait
de la variété du divertissement au
service d'une bonne cause
on va arrêter les politiques d'accord
avec [ __ ] moi ça me gonfle vraiment
sérieusement un truc voilà sais c'est
que du bon quoi donc je me suis posé la
question comment sont choisis les
nouveaux [ __ ] et jullet réponse et
il faut que chacun des nouveaux artistes
puissent individuellement remplir un
zénith à au moins donc à bourgoin alors
là je vous dit votre info dans le
casting va qui remplissent même pas ma
chambre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui d'accord mais j'ai une info pour
faire les en forêt faut faire un stade
de france
vous dites ne dit rien et ça passe nous
sommes certains s'avèrent tout passe
tout lasse au flat glass allez on y va
rappeler que ce profit des restos du
coeur et wissant 6 à 20 millions par
rapport aux 20 millions d'euros c'est
gigantesque
franchement moi je n'ai qu'un mot à dire
regardons les [ __ ] achetons et des
bd la mode paris voilà exactement c'est
important merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]